hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today I'll be talking about uh the
aggressive traders in the market and you
know they was election day in the US and
we had this nice uh big run up from
um you know just after the cash opened
we dropped down
um about uh 15 20 points almost and then
we had this huge rally all the way up to
65 and
um you know it sort of went sideways and
then it really just fell off off the
cliff
um after 12 and then actually it uh
rallied right back up towards uh I mean
didn't get up towards a high but it got
back up towards the 55
um you know before closing uh the day at
uh you know what was that around 38 33
or so I forgot the exact number but um
you know I want to talk about the
aggressive trading that was taking place
in the market and you know how you can
use that to your to your advantage now
you know
people like to say well Market was up
because there was more buyers and
sellers you know or the market was down
because there's more sellers than buyers
well that's not really you know an extra
accurate uh portrayal of the market
you know for every buyer there is a
seller but what causes the markets to go
up and go down are the aggressive
Traders okay now you have basically two
types of Traders you have aggressive
Traders and you have passive Traders
think of it like this okay markets trade
in a two-way auction
you know there's a bid in the there's an
offer people that are working a bid or
working an offer those are the passive
Traders the sellers that cross the bid
offer line and hit the bid sell into the
bid or lift the offer buy the offer
those are the aggressive Traders and you
know don't get too confused by that you
know it's it sounds more complex than it
really is but think of it like this
right I mean we've all bought a house or
you know we've all thought about buying
a house and
you know that you look you know you look
online at wherever realtor.com you see a
nice house that you like it's a half a
million dollars but
you don't want to pay a half a million
dollars you only want to pay 400 000 so
there's a seller he's a passive seller
at four hundred thousand dollars I'm
sorry at 500 000 at half a million he's
the passive seller if you pay his asking
price you are the aggressive buyer
because you want to get that house you
want to get a home now if you think you
know I like this house but I only want
to pay 400 000 you submit a bid
four hundred thousand for the house if
the seller's like ah you know what uh
interest rates are going up you know
less people are buying houses I just
want to get this off you know get get
this house sold and he goes down and
hits your bid he's like sold sell it to
you for four hundred thousand that
seller he crossed the bid offer line it
was 400 000 at 500 000.
so he crossed that he was the aggressive
seller okay so I mean that's it in a
basic sense right so we're all seeing
aggression every day you know in
um you know everyday markets okay buying
a car you know you you go to a dealer
there's a sticker price you know you
guys negotiate back and forth that's the
two-way auction
um so aggressive trading is what causes
imbalances and the order in the order
flow now this could mean different
things okay one it could just simply
mean a large order is making its way
through the market which causes an
imbalance okay so for example you know
you see this here you know like this bar
right in the middle 105 22 86. you know
maybe someone just had a large order
they're coming through the market and
they're just slowly lifting the offers
okay
that is what you know happens all day
long in the markets you know people with
big orders are working their orders into
the market try not to move it too much
now or it gets interesting is
sort of the
passive
buyers causing absorption in the markets
okay now for example you see this green
candle
right but it's got a selling a balance
122 against 23.
and you know it's a selling a balance so
you think there's aggressive sellers in
the market like you know there's
aggressive sellers are in control yeah
it's causing a selling imbalance why
isn't this Market moving down well it's
met with some passive buying right some
strong bidding to absorb whatever
aggressive selling is taking place in
the market right you see another one up
here the 251 here you see 108 here you
see 76 these are all green candles right
and it's like generally markets go up
you're looking for
the
um buying imbalances right in the green
candles that's what you expect to see on
a market going up
on markets going down you know the red
candles you expect to see selling
imbalances and you see here 85 here's a
41 here's a 143.
so work is interesting is obviously when
you got those green candles right the
green candles with the selling
imbalances or the red candles with the
mine imbalances so
oftentimes when you see the red candles
with buying imbalances it's it's people
coming in with Supply in the market
right as the market is dropping down
people that have Supply want to get rid
of it because you know they want to sell
it now rather than at lower prices
but when a market is rallying it's
starting to go up and you start seeing
selling imbalances in
the green candles you know that's a sign
of absorption
so you know you got it
not just take it on its face value that
oh my gosh they're selling the balances
I got to get short
right because it could be a sign of
absorption and today you know when we're
rallying there was some really big size
coming in right at this was at 10 24.
big size in the market I mean look at
this 1151 against 262. this bar right
here as we're breaking out through these
new Highs at 55 big buyer another big
buyer you know it's probably the same
buyer someone's just bidding it up and
when you see that in the market
pay attention to it because it's often
you know a sign of you know obviously
someone is supporting the market and if
the market is going up and you see
support coming into a market chances are
the market can go higher I mean we did
go higher uh we just we shot up to you
know 67 that's a quick 12 point move it
did pull back a little bit but then you
start seeing the aggressive buying
coming in again buying a balance buying
a balance buying a balance more buying
imbalances you know on the way up so
again don't take it on its
face value thinking oh you know because
I got this big selling balance 11.51
the market should be going down well
it's not right we're trading above that
it's it's a sign of absorption I don't
want to call it trap Traders per se you
know that's a phrase that gets used very
Loosely
um by Traders trying to describe
something that you know my opinion isn't
uh really a fair representation of the
market
but when there's
you're dealing with imbalances you know
depending on where the imbalances appear
in a bar it can be significant okay and
you know we do have tools like in our
our order flows Trader software to
identify you know trap Traders
um in the order flow okay so you know
for example
um you have what's called an imbalance
reversal okay and I'll just pull it up
here right this is you know my regular
footprint chart
uh well you know I'll just go back to my
chart that I was you know I like to use
this one for the YouTube videos because
it's just a plain footprint chart
because I like to shoot the videos for
people that
um you know have other software and can
learn something but an imbalance
reversal I'll just draw it here
um
light green let's make it a little
darker so it's a little easier to see in
the video
um you know it's basically a sign is
using
imbalances right the selling imbalances
in green up candles or buying a balances
in red Down Candles as a sign of
potentially trapped Traders right
because it's not what you're expecting
to see and what it is it's a sign of
Supply coming into the market you know
as
um you know in the red candles as the
price is trading lower you have someone
coming in and you know offering it
offering it offering it or bidding it
bidding it bidding it you know on green
candles green up candles so let's see
here you know here's a perfect example
one right here all right 160 right you
see how the market sold right down off
of that right Market is selling off
and as a sign off you know people with
supplier coming in saying hey you know
what let's uh you know I know I'd rather
sell it as much as I can up here I don't
want to necessarily push the market
so I'll just work the offers right
they're passive sellers but they're
absorbing whatever aggressive buying is
taking place it's 25 against 160. and
you see the market you know sold off
came right back up to that area where
you had that Supply coming in earlier
um there was a level up here now these
are being drawn until tested so if it
comes back you know in any bars it's
going to stop drawing it just says you
know over here was the level and it
stopped I mean you could draw it out
until tested or you can draw it out um
you know a fixed level but it came back
right to that level right traded five
Lots another five lots and then it
dropped down now here's a bullish one
okay now it came in
Market started to Rally then just went
sideways uh before falling this was that
big sell-off you can see here we got
this green from much earlier
um you know before I started talking
here was a bullish one here
but this was that earlier here about 9
30 right this is an imbalance reversal
all right this is support coming into
the market
as this Market is moving up and I mean
look at that this is coming in right at
what 9 30 to you know when we're trading
around 38 uh you know 38 38 and we
rallied all the way up to you know 10
quick 10 points
okay and this level held for quite some
time it did eventually come back there
um you know in the afternoon here at 12.
I don't know if there's any more you
know here's a small bullish one here at
one o'clock it was a small bearish one
just sort of went down then you got this
nice one here at 3821
um you know so I mean you could have
been selling it you know after this bar
closes you know 38 18 and all the way
down to below 3 800 down into these new
lows here
right where you had a bullish one but it
just came right back into it so you know
that's how you can identify
you know signs of absorption
um you know again I I wouldn't you know
people will call it trap Traders and I
hate to use that term
because I mean you see these volumes
it's nine against 58 58 Lots trapped
that's not really trapped you know if it
was 580 yeah I'd consider that trapped
but
um it's really you know it's what we
call an imbalance reversal it's you know
people that have Supply to absorb
whatever
um aggressive buying is taking place
right and it's a great way to identify
um you know trade trade opportunities in
the market
so
you know hopefully you're coming away
and understanding that you know
imbalances
have the sort of dual meanings right
they are you know a sign of aggressive
trading but it can also be a sign of
absorption or distribution taking place
in the markets okay so I hope you guys
enjoyed this video you know over the
weekend I released a course uh
situational
order flow trading course and you know
it's been getting you know people have
been writing back towards me uh you know
telling me hey you know that that's
actually a nice course
um you know they're learning a few
things like a few new
um order flow based setups that they
could use and again you know if you're
interested in it if you haven't seen
I'll put the link in the chat or another
chat in the description below but you
know this is what it is you just go to
orderflows.com backslash uh forward
slash rather situational and you know
this is the pages you know everything
that you'll learn in here
um you know things like combining price
action with order flow signs the market
is about to shift based on the order
flow you know some order flow price
patterns that's going to help you
predict the next big moves you know one
order flow is sending mixed messages
you know if you can detect Market
manipulation in the footprint you know
it's difficult you know I see a lot of
people complaining about manipulation in
the market but you know really you can't
trade in fear that there's manipulation
out there and there is you know cfdc
still catches people for doing
you know things like spoofing you know
even though everybody knows spoofing is
is not legal
um you know people think they're going
to beat the system for some reason
um then they end up getting caught uh
structural and active order flow what
the differences are how to use it then I
discuss you know a bunch of uh price
pattern setups you know with the order
flow you know of course it'll talk about
risk and then we wrap everything up and
you know right now it's on a special
it's only 99 off it's 297 this is a new
course you know it's different than all
the other courses I've released so again
you know if you're interested in it the
link is below and again you know thanks
for watching this video be sure to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
trying to get some more videos up you
know I sort of went on Hiatus for a
little while I just had a lot of stuff
to catch up on you know Halloween is
always a big
a big holiday at my house and uh it took
a while for me to recover so thanks
everyone have a great day bye bye